so i'm really i've really wondered many
times if um
if really
i'm going to start here and then we'll
grow the idea um if we just kind of come
and go evolutionary as humans like some
variation of human kind of just comes
and goes and it's just we're like an
ecosystem to the planet
like it's just you know you just get too
big you get too greedy
whatever it is and earth swallows you up
and says let's start again and we can
continue on with that but what do you
think about that idea and is there any
evidence that
shows that yeah i mean i do think if you
if you look at you know the evolution of
species it's like you you cut it or you
don't you compete and if you don't make
it you don't make it i mean there's no
question that like
we could as a species like the most
obvious game in and ender for us right
is nuclear
war right so we as a species could uh
get to such a point where somebody
finally pushes one of these buttons
because there are these you know these
these um
weapons all over the world and we could
go and have a
a nuclear war which would uh not only
kill a lot of people what would poison a
lot of the planet and i don't think
humanity would be erased but it would be
like a you know biblical setback um and
we would probably have to kind of
become you know scrape our way out of
the ashes and start over i mean i yeah i
think that what about going into earth
what about going inner earth then to
hide from it and what about what about
what about inner earth people
no there's no inner earth people
you've been watching you're watching
king kong movies too much oh yeah i am
watching king kong and all kinds of
other crazy stuff on youtube i love i
mean we can build a bunch of
shelters and live down there and life
would be pretty miserable i mean what's
the difference between that and like
inner earth i mean like if you have to
go inside the earth to wait out the
storm why didn't couldn't somebody else
have done that yeah but there's no
sunlight down there there's no food like
how do you grow anything how do you get
what if they have their own ark and the
ark makes some light sanica i am
proposing many crazy things because i
love to get a reaction and hear what
takes what gets traction you know if you
think there's a bunch of morlocks
hanging around down there walking around
in their secret underground chambers
to me first of all let's just think
about it this way if you were one of
these underground people who the hell
would want to live underground why
wouldn't you just come up through a
sewer grate and be like enough of this i
want to be out here where it's sunny i
think the teenage mutant ninja turtles
did that right yeah i mean
i am
i just think
that yes to answer your first question
yeah the earth can swallow us up like
the bugs that we are and and yeah and i
think that and covet i think was a
little bit of a wake-up call that like
you can have especially because of how
globalized we are now in air travel and
we just are constantly in each other's
right every day thousands of people are
crossing borders millions of people are
crossing borders so um
yeah a a plague um a weapon a bio weapon
a nuclear weapon yeah like we are not
we are not
any safer from extinction than okay
or the dinosaurs a meteor could hit the
planet okay let's hop skip and jump to
another crazy idea because you've you've
done some stuff around it but um
extraterrestrials i mean
okay here's my take i 100
believe in extraterrestrials there is no
doubt anyone who doesn't think that
there isn't life somewhere else in the
universe is at this point
it's a really hard argument to make i
mean the data just shows
that
there are
earth-like planets there are planets
that sit in this sweet spot in other
solar systems of course there are right
and those conditions of sunlight and an
atmosphere you know we know things will
grow so i mean i just
think that
as each day march is on you it's just
becoming clearer and clearer that the
probability is just overwhelming that
there's life in the universe
whether it's been here and is like
skulking around in the shadows i am much
more skeptical about now there are
things that i have seen some of these
videos these navy videos that show these
high speed i mean i don't know what they
are i don't have all the answers there's
just something to me
a little
i i have sort of a hard time believing
that they're here or they've been here
and they're just kind of
hiding and
taking cows and testing on them and
stuff i don't know i just it it does
seem like
i guess my theory is that life exists in
the universe but it is rare like it's i
mean rare meaning you have to travel a
long way to find it so i would think
that if given the fact that there are
like trillions of galaxies or billions
yeah so so like maybe not rare
mathematically but probably rare
that any one species could ever reach
another right that because in order to
do that you not only have to
not blow yourselves up and become so
advanced that you can create some sort
of technology that is way ahead of where
we are to create faster than light
travels so you you have to you have to
stay on the planet you mean the stuff
that we're talking about right now
getting off the planet you mean the
stuff that we're doing right now yeah
but but like but but to reach another
planet of people we are so far from that
baby steps man we're like
but that's what i'm saying like you
gotta hang around long enough that you
don't get wiped out by
another civilization a meteor a plague
of whatever you have to survive long
enough to become that advanced and then
i feel like if you pull that off and
you're gonna go all the way across the
universe
you're gonna go and like not hide you're
gonna be like what's up we're here we
did it i don't buy
this whole they're they're they're all
sneaky why are they sneaky
why are aliens sneaky
because they're different and we'd freak
out
like what would you do if you saw if you
saw even if you saw like bigfoot or
like something crazy that we don't know
if really exists but maybe and and this
is like within our psyche even and if
you saw it and it kind of resembles this
and that and you put them together and
you're like oh you'd still freak the
hell out you'd still be like this is
legitimate you run or you'd shoot it and
you'd test it yes
right this is the sort of childhood's
end or like this is like a star trek
thing this is this is the prime
directive in star trek you don't mess
with the civilization with it with a
planet that's more primitive than you
because it will totally alter their
development because they'll start
worshiping you or trying to kill you or
whatever i guess
that's sound thinking i mean i'm a big
star trek fan so i i get it
but i just kind of think
i don't know i just haven't seen
anything
compelling enough to have me say
yes that's what i think happening stop
it you've been to like all of these
crazy places in the world that you can't
explain how things were built and how
they had the technology and why is it so
perfect and why is it
astrologically aligned and such
perfection why does this why does
stonehenge line up perfectly with the
solstice like why do all these things
exist like did they really have the
technology
i'm giving these ancient people more
credit
i i think that that it is remarkable
what you can do
if you are laser focused on it like
you know people talk about
i mean stonehenge okay yeah stonehenge
is astronomically fascinating but like
look at it it's pretty like home spun
it's a bunch of blocks that are kind of
but they're megalithic stones though i
know but like but it's not like some
laser cut alien like hundreds of miles
away
i know but i think they rolled them on
wood on logs really
let me tell you something never this is
this is my one big counter argument
to uh people who believe in like alien
intervention stuff never underestimate
the ability to do difficult things if
you don't have much else to do
i'm serious like if you're in egypt
you're like okay i'm the pharaoh um it's
a million degrees i got the nile we're
making food things are happening i'm a
i'm a you know egomaniac
i want a giant thing built uh and i'm
the pharaoh so everybody's gonna you
know either i'm gonna pay this workforce
or i'm gonna enslave people that's a big
debate but i think that most of it are
like workers
and it's like nobody has anything else
to do
build me this thing
i mean look what taylor swift did with
the pandemic man she made some albums
she got busy she got busy this is what
i'm saying that's her stonehenge
i'm telling you if you have nothing else
to do
can do a lot
and if you have enough people
all of these places where there's
pyramids and giant constructions they
never it's not like they're happening in
places where nobody's around there with
these huge population centers where it's
like these people need something to do
we're going to put them on this pyramid
project
so you've been to egypt you know the
nile you've been on the nile i've been
on the nile you've been down to ask
aswan you've been you've been to
probably the quarry where they
supposedly got all of their stones like
i have two and you're like oh here and
then you think oh
okay it's going on boats
have you seen those boats they don't
look real shut they don't look real
sharp and then you think to yourself and
how did they even get the big stones
onto the boat like it just does not make
sense it it you danica you've got to
give them more crap i can't i won't i
know what people i won't do it human
nature has to do the minimum back then
they could have just like sailed off
into the desert when you go to these
quarries
um the big one is down at silsilla which
is this cool egyptian quarry there are
like obelisk
shaped
notches missing from the walls like
they're clearly popping huge blocks out
of these walls right
and
we know
that
not all of them made it like there's big
chunks of blocks in the bottom of the
nile like our boat didn't work right
like you can see that they're trying
stuff and they're moving things and by
the way
when you went to egypt you probably saw
the bent pyramid they messed up a
pyramid they got halfway up and they
were like ah [ __ ] and then they had to
change the angle on it so like you can
see that they're working on it but i'm
telling you i'm sticking with my theory
which is
if you don't have much to do you can do
a lot
what have you done the last three weeks
nothing
see
kept my children alive that's difficult
that's actually always hard
[Music]
you